I work too hard to you know just drop
the ball like that and I got to accept
that CH and that's
okay still touch my hands it's all good
it's all good touch my hands uh but next
year I won't be in that position ever
again ever again we've been repping that
play all week um I knew that play was
for me um and when we caught it it was
just all about making a play um and when
that ball came to me I happened to fail
today um but hey I'm Standing Tall it's
it's over a lot of the guys came up to
me keep your head up you know what I'm
saying um never lose my confidence so
just just keep just keep being me and
keep being myself um and that's what I'm
going to continue to do